des études de baccalauréat en génie ou
en sciences ou encore des études
doctorales en médecine semble être la
carte maîtresse qu'il faut posséder
avant même de songer postuler la
première fois qu'elle est le comité
sélectionne l'agent staff elles vont
nous voir un personne parce que à
travers le processus si on regarde et
nous priver d'examens médicaux un
douzième du calcio mais c'est la
première fois qu'ils vont devoir à
personne ça fait que mon devoir et rire
ils vont nous voir
originaire de rouyn noranda donc au nord
du québec
un autre québécois pourrait être le
prochain astronaute de l'agencé spatiale
canadienne
charles philippe l'a joint travaillent
présentement comme scientifique
d'instruments astronomiques aux tic à
baltimore donc aux états unis sur le
télescope spatial james webb à projets
dirigés à la fois par la nasa l'agencé
spatiale canadienne et l' agence
spatiale européenne que vous avez eu la
chance de regarder la livre des forces
des deux écrivains tous les domaines de
la vie au temps des rancoeurs son pilote
de chasse
pourtant que des gens qui sont bien
logique marins ou géologie avec des gens
qui vient de tous les domaines qui
donnent tous ces gens là vont est évalué
sur les mêmes épreuves on peut on a
besoin plus parce que en un an 90 ans de
confiance et le thé mais on peut lever
moi je veux que ça reste intéressant
pour quelqu'un qui aime nous parler des
filles
l'agencé spatiale canadienne a lancé
donc un appel de candidatures l'été
dernier pour recruter deux nouveaux
astronautes
on tournait au dessus de 3050 20 heures
le gestionnaire de projet pour la
campagne de recrutement de l'agencé
spatiale canadienne
karlstad indique que ce deux candidats
parmi les 3700 candidatures initialement
reçu pour concrétiser leur rêve
on est à notre quatrième campagne de la
dernière lieu en 2008 et elle avait
aussi précéder la même façon en ce
moment à la limite je souhaitais pas
encore fait comme en fait nous du compte
maintenant de l'omniprésence des médias
sociaux c'était c'était la façon avec
laquelle on a promu la campagne le
chemin on voulait s'assurer que les gens
qui ont ce rêve je sois au courant
cui plus possible j'ai rêvé encore
alexandre coupé roy chercheur
postdoctoral en physique atomique à
l'institut de technologie de la
californie est l'un des candidats
choisis par l' agence spatiale
canadienne pour faire partie de la
courte liste comptait pour moi de le
faire
j'avais à l'idée à la fois de de pouvoir
servir le canada et et si possible
d'aller dans l'espace pour continuer à
faire des expériences scientifiques et
possiblement également aller sur mars
donc c'est en fait ça rejoint de libé de
l'exploration donc il ya l'exploration
intellectuelle et que tu veux dire à la
fois donc essayer de découvrir de
nouvelles choses mais également de
d'aller à des endroits qui n'ont jamais
été explorées par exemple la planète la
1/2 oui j'ai commencé quand le ter -
juin 2009 devenant le lieutenant-colonel
jeremy hansen pilote de 41 ans au sein
des forces canadiennes est aujourd'hui
un des trois astronautes canadiens au
sein des 47 que compte pour le moment la
nasa on fait beaucoup des choses bien
sonné dans le vieux
plus de succès des examens pour autant
pouvoir commencer pour sa part réagi le
projet sur les timbres le dessin en ce
moment prévoit donc des missions
humaines vers la lune jusqu'en 2030 et
par la suite vers mars les astronautes
canadiens par dessus tout en plus des
diplômes doivent avoir comme qualité
principale la patience atteindre
l'espace est l'objectif ultime d'une
carrière et cela peut prendre des années
que pendant trois ans je suis un peu
disparu à l'école les astronautes
différentes formations a complété il
faut un pilotage la robotique
comment faire des sorties spatiales
servir du scaphandre apprend par les
russes le québécois david saint-jacques
a appris en 2016 qui serait le prochain
astronaute canadien à visiter la station
spatiale internationale en 2018
le jour où on m'a embauchée je suis pas
soudainement est devenu un astronaute ça
prend des années des années pour un
change un peu la maison qu'on pense on
peut imaginer peut-être un peu comme un
mélange entre retourner à l'université
et puis peut-être devenir pilote mais en
même temps devenir un peu comme un
militaire dans ce sens où on est dans
une structure taper un mélange de tous
aux astronautes on est on est la partie
la plus visible d'une immense et qui
plus que j'ai encore 29 samedi par le
teint bien sûr le québécois daniel
desjardins originaire de la gaspésie a
été retranché lui récemment pour des
raisons médicales
c'est ce qu'ont à deux fois après avoir
vécu émeutes ont un écran de ce manque
de fonds de ne pas avoir pu continuer ce
soit de base au sommet mais de me
plaindre ou de voir le côté positif et
c'est sûr qu'en fin de journée quand on
poursuit nos rêves on est rayé trier
donc je n'ai aucun regret je n'ai pas
grandi de ces instincts et
je suis extrêmement content de mon
rendement avec un dernier vient selon un
reportage de radio canada international